>> HE WILL GET ALL HIGHFALUTIN
WHEN HE SITS DOWN WITH VLADIMIR.
THIS WEEK PRESIDENT MEETING WIT
VLADIMIR PUTIN WAS SAID TO BE
COOLER THAN ICE ON A DAIQUIRI.
BUT ACCORDING TO JOE IS GOING T
CRASH A.
COMPARE THAT TO THIS 2018 WHERE
THEY MORPH THEM INTO THE SAME
PERSON THEY ARE SIDE-BY-SIDE TOO
.
PRODUCERS, GOOD JOB.
WHAT A DIFFERENCE BY US CAN MAK
GREAT SPEAKING OF DRUM, HE STIL
GRACES IS EVER WISHING BIDEN
WELL IN E-MAIL, GOOD LUCK TO
BIDEN IN DEALING WITH VLADIMIR
PUTIN.
DON'T FALL ASLEEP DURING THE
MEETING AND PLEASE, GIVE ME IT
GAVE GIVE HIM MY BEST REGARDS
VERY JOE SHOULD ALSO REMIND
HIMSELF BEFORE HAND THAT HE IS
PRESIDENT BECAUSE HE TENDS TO
FORGET.
THOUGH WHO KNOWS IF JOE WILL BE
UP TO THE TASK FIRST HE CONFUSE
SERIAL WITH LIBYA.
>> WE CAN WORK TOGETHER WITH
RUSSIA FOR EXAMPLE IN LIBYA,
THEY HAVE ALSO BITTEN OFF
SEVERAL PROBLEMS ARE GOING TO
HAVE TROUBLE CHEWING ON.
FOR EXAMPLE THE REBUILDING OF
SYRIA, LIBYA.
I AM HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN FIND
ACCOMMODATION WHERE WE CAN SAVE
THE LIVES OF PEOPLE AND FOR
EXAMPLE IN LIBYA.
>> THAT'S LIKE CONFUSING CANADA
WITH CLIENTS.
HE ALSO JOKED ABOUT HIS HANDLER
CONTROLLING THE NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS HE TAKES AND FROM WHO
ALTHOUGH IT DIDN'T SEEM LIKE HE
WANTED TO ANSWER.
>> I'M SORRY, JENNIFER JACOB
BLOOMBERG GREAT I'M GOING TO GE
IN TROUBLE WITH MY STAFF, GO
AHEAD.
>> THEY KEPT IN PLACE SOME
TRUMPED, AND I WANTED TO ASK YO
WHEN YOU WERE HAVING THESE
CONVERSATIONS WITH EUROPEAN
ALLIES, WHERE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE SANCTIONS, HOW DO YOU
TESTIFY TO THAT.
>> IT WAS 20 DAYS, GIVE ME A
BREAK.
>> THAT IS AGREED GREAT DARTH
VADER.
I'VE GOT TO CHILL UP MY SPINE.
THAT IS ONLY THE THIRD WORST
AWKWARD MOMENT FROM THE SUMMIT
AFTER THIS PICTURE VERY
VERITABLY GET THAT, PREVIOUS
CHESS PIECES I HAVE EVER SEEN.
THEN THERE WAS THE BUMP TEST.
>> FUN FUN FACT, THAT IS HOW
YIELDS MEET.
IT'S LIKE JEFF STUCKER SAID, YO
SHOULDN'T DO THAT ON CAMERA.
ARIGHT, WHAT YOU MAKE OF THIS
WHOLE THING?
>> I'M NOT REALLY SURE WHERE
THEY'RE GOING WITH THIS WHOLE
JOE BIDEN AVIATOR SUNGLASSES
LOOK.
I DON'T KNOW WHO THAT IS FOOLIN
BECAUSE OF VISA PILOT I THINK
HE'S WELL PAST THE FAA'S
RETIREMENT.
BEFORE SAYING THIS BIDEN REMIND
HIM OF FRANKLIN ROOSEVELT.
IT'S MORE LIKE A ROOSEVELT
ROOSEVELT FROM 1926.
>> ON THE WAY DOWN.
>> IT KIND OF REMINDS ME OF
ELEANOR.
DOES THIS SHOW YOU THAT IT'S
MORE THEATER.
I FINALLY REALIZED HOW MUCH OF
THIS IS JUST THEATER.
IT TOOK TRUMP TO KIND OF SHAKE
THE BOX FOR ME TO SEE THAT THIS
IS JUST A BUNCH OF A WASTE OF
TIME.
IN MY WRONG?
>> NO, YOU'RE NOT WRONG AT ALL.
>> ALL RIGHT, NOAKES QUESTION.
>> TRUMP, WATCHING PRESS
CONFERENCE HE WOULD SAY THAT WA
SO CRAZY, THAT WAS A WILD.
TRUMP SUPPORTERS ALL KNEW THAT
IT WAS CRAZY, BUT THEY WERE JUS
INTO THAT.
THERE LIKE THAT GREAT I WISH
THAT PEOPLE ON THE LEFT COULD B
MORE HONEST ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING NOW.
NOW THINGS ARE BACK TO NORMAL.
THIS IS NOT NORMAL.
YOU CAN'T WATCH ONE OF THOSE AN
SAY THAT THAT IS ANYTHING CLOSE
TWO NORMAL.
PRESIDENTS NORMALLY KNOW WHERE
THEY ARE CONFIDENTLY AT A
MINIMUM, AND THEN CAN EVEN GO
THE EXTRA MILE AND BE ABLE TO
COMPETENTLY ANSWER QUESTIONS
VERY THAT'S NOT HAPPENING AND
WERE NOT SEEING THAT
ACKNOWLEDGMENT FROM ANYBODY.
>> AT LEAST HE'S NOT TWEETING
AND THAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING.
>> I DON'T THINK HE COULD.
>> AND WHO CARES, WHO CARES IF
THE PRESIDENT THANKS LIBYA IN
SYRIA AND SYRIA IS LIBYA, HE SO
MUCH NICER THAN TRUMP.
>> YOU KNOW, WE'VE GONE THROUGH
SOME PRESIDENTS THAT WANTED TO
JUST GO TO WAR WITH ALL OF THEM
ANYWAY, I DON'T KNOW THAT IT
MATTERS.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT IN MY CAR
RIGHT NOW, I HOPE WE FIND OUT
HE'S A BIG POTHEAD AND HE'S BEE
HIGH, AND RELEASE BECAUSE AT
THAT POINT I UNDERSTAND IT AND
I'M NOT CONCERNED ABOUT HIS
HEALTH.
I HATE TO SAY IT APPEARS, BUT
YOU CAN TURN PUNK 18 -YEAR-OLD
INTO A MARINE WITH HONOR,
COURAGE, AND COMMITMENT IN 90
DAYS.
MOST REHAB FACILITIES THAT TAKE
YOU ALL FOR WHATEVER HAS CONTRO
OVER YOUR LIFE ARE 30-60 DAYS
AND LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING,
GREG, I'VE HAD LEGS REMOVED TWO
MY BODY TO STANDING UP IN 110
DAYS.
BUT IN 120 DAYS HE CAN'T DECIDE
WHAT HE THINKS ABOUT THE
POLICIES HE'S GOT ELECTED
ATTACKING WHAT HE SHOULD DO
ABOUT THEM.
WHO ARE YOU INTIMIDATING?
THERE IS NOTHING INTIMIDATING G
GOING ON THERE.
>> HE'S ALSO BEEN THERE FOR 40
OR 50 YEARS.
WHAT IS 120 DAYS.
>> "AMERICA REPORTS" IS ANT I
THINK WE HAVE GOT MORE BIDEN
NEWS CONFERENCES THAN ANY OTHER
SHOW ON THE NETWORK AND JUST LE
ME TELL YOU, IT WOULD BE A GOOD
THING IF PEOPLE WERE WATCHING
THEM.
I THINK THEY JUST LEAVE WHEN IT
HAPPENS, BUT WE'VE NOTICED SOME
TRENDS WITH THE QUESTION TAKEN
WITH BIDEN YOU WILL NOTICE AND
YOU JUST SHOWED THAT THERE HE
PICKS UP THE FOLDER AT THE END.
HE'S THE PRESIDENT, HE'S GOT
SOMEBODY TO PICK THE FOLDER OVE
HIM.
HE'S GOT THIS MOVE IF HE DOESN'
HAVE PLANS, QUESTIONS THAT IS
GOING TO TAKE PRETTY CANDID
WANTS TO FIELD ONE OR TWO, HE H
PICKS UP THE FIELDER, HE IS
WALKING AWAY, HE WANTS TO GRAB
IT, HE'LL TAKE IT.
AND THEN HE SAYS HE'LL GET IN
TROUBLE WITH HIS STAFF.
THE FIST BUMPING BOGGLES ME.
ARE THEY ALL VACCINATED ADULTS?
LEADERS OF THE COUNTRIES?
>> EVERYBODY JUST APPEARS SO
SMALL WHEN THEY DO THAT STUFF.
>> IT'S LIKE THEY'RE HAVING FUN.
THEY DID A WHOLE MOVE, THEY WEN
OUT TO THE LEFT IN THEM BACK
WITH THE WHOLE BODY